the run I want the money 10,000 bucks we  need cash fast remember that dude Utah  in the desert got stuck under that rock  had a chop off his arm - made a killing  from selling his story I'm missing up on  that mountain right there well we'd have  a hell of a story know ten days is  nothing home sweet home  we need people to think I'm jealous and  I'd want to kill you  you had a fight the night before  something happened No  then why was he so pissed we're not that  kind of money what are you talking about  unfortunately I don't bleeding good for  me looks miles miles he's not here  I need to talk me ash he screwed you I  did it because I loved you  you can't pull out now  mom  down in these  Man Alive is decreasing no evidence of  foul play in the disappearance  you